what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Venom basically wrapping
this up which gets us current with Venom
here in 2023 which actually allows us to
segue into dark web although we do need
to cover a little bit of Spider-Man not
the whole thing as well as maybe New
Mutants but that's not overly necessary
because I know enough history about
Madeleine Pryor that I can basically
give you the skinny without having to
cover the entire story so the thing
about this is that if you recall the
video that we finished off with when it
came to the most recent Venom story that
we did that one largely focused on Eddie
Brock which is to say when he met Kang
when he was being trained by Kang of
course if you're unfamiliar with this
make sure you check the playlist down in
the description so you can get caught up
on Venom as we stand right now but this
story focuses more on Dylan and the
reason for that is because in the last
video that we did one of the things we
discussed is how Dylan was ultimately
captured and really defeated by the life
Foundation now the life Foundation again
is this organization that had existed
for quite some time it was always
studying symbiotes trying to find a way
to weaponize them and basically hand
them out to the highest bidder or to
launch their own individual campaigns in
this instance with Dylan having been
caught and captured the Venom symbiote
was forced to flee just because of the
fact that the Symbiote itself was too
weak to heal Dylan and to keep the fight
going now because of the fact that it
was tasked with ensuring the safety of
Dylan what it did is it actually
extracted Dylan's Consciousness now this
is an interesting thing because this is
one of those situations where Marvel's
always sort of built on this in some
capacity and people do it in different
ways for example Tony Stark was able to
upload his Consciousness to a computer
system and then re-download it into a
new body when he had died in Civil War
or at least Civil War II but of course
in the aftermath of all of this Dylan's
Consciousness is physically inside the
Symbiote itself and so what it does and
really what Dylan does is he wakes up in
a kind of dream space right which is
really not that dissimilar from the
Leviathan in the Hellraiser Series right
to be honest with you guys it's actually
Dylan sort of making his way through
here and not fully understanding what's
going on now the beauty about this is of
course as he's in this in this kind of
dimensional realm where this sort of
ethereal mind of the Venom symbiote he's
attacked by all these different
manifestations of the Venom samid itself
if each one of which really kind of
represents the symbiote's own corruption
or some facet of the Symbiote we're not
really given a whole lot of details here
it's just kind of designed to show what
the inside of the mindscape of the
Symbiote looks like of course Dylan
because of the fact that he's familiar
with symbiotes and even for reasons that
he's not entirely sure of he's actually
able to Fashion mandibles and things
like that of his own accord that
basically deal and take out all these
different symbiotes that are there now
of course they end up fleeing he doesn't
necessarily destroy them but they end up
fleeing because there's the arrival of a
person in a purple robe now my initial
thought here as soon as I saw this and
I'm sorry to destroy so many people's
expectations is that this was mistress
death because nine times out of ten in
Marvel Comics mistress death shows up in
some kind of a blue or purple robe and
literally looks exactly like this it's
not mistress death truth to tell it
wouldn't really make a whole lot of
sense that mistress death was here but
what this what this really kind of
disembodied person does is it strikes up
a conversation with Dylan and starts
talking to him and it simply refers to
the fact that it's the keeper that its
job here is to stay and to literally
keep things in in a reasonable order and
in fact he asked do you know the meaning
of the word clintard Dillon Brock it
means cage now the other part of this
equation is what's going on in the real
world this deals with sleeper now
sleeper is a symbiote that's just kind
of been lightly touched on when it came
to alguing's run and in fact it's
largely just been in the background the
whole time it just took on the form of a
cat this is kind of considered the
personal protector of Dylan in the case
that like the Venom symbiote somehow
ends up unable to do so which is
literally this exact situation one of
the things that sleeper does is it
actually goes and it meets with archer
Archer of course being the woman that
had handed Dylan over to the life
Foundation although she didn't
necessarily realize she was doing that
at the time but it basically betrayed
Dylan and so when sleeper meets with her
one of the things it figures out right
off the bat is she regrets her decision
and where she initially kind of comes to
him with this idea of like breaking into
the life foundation and trying to steal
back the body of Dylan that's a Fool's
errand you're inevitably going to get
yourself killed the response of sleeper
is you drastically underestimate what
I'm capable of and the other thing he
says is there was a point where himself
and another guy named Hank had basically
been bonded together now Hank Hensley is
a character who's actually an old friend
of Flash Thompson and in fact what had
happened is that there was a point when
sleeper had bonded to Hank Hensley in
order to effectively defeat the Carnage
symbia but one of the things sleeper had
done is that in realizing a situation
may arise at a future point in time when
it needs to act either with some kind of
a duplicate or some in some capacity
basically this situation right now that
what it did is it left a piece of itself
attached to Hank Hensley so while Hank
has no real idea what's going on the
sleeper symbiote inside of Hank
activates and what it does is it
actually sends him into Motion in facing
off against the forces of the life
Foundation now kind of jumping back to
Dylan Brock here for a second because
this story is going to get absolutely
awesome the keeper actually reveals its
identity to Dylan which of course as
most people probably expected turns out
to be Eddie Brock himself or at least
kind of a vision of Eddie block because
to Dylan's eyes it's his death now of
course what ends up happening here is
the keeper says I'm not really your dad
I'm just a manifestation of your dad
your dad's basically dead right like
he's in the afterlife for symbiotes or
whatever it is dealing with Meridius and
all that kind of stuff and learning that
Meridius is eventually the person that
he becomes he's got his own story arc
and of course for that we covered that
in the last video now this is where
things start to get a little bit cryptic
because the keeper takes Dylan to that
giant geode looking thing with the
chains attached to it in the middle of
this whole landscape and when Dylan asks
what's in there the response of the
keeper is Venom is in there and then in
turn he says but if you're going to make
it through there you're going to need to
understand the truth and when Dylan
proposes he's just kind of uh confused
here the response of this Eddie Vision
whatever it is whatever you want to call
it says your Consciousness here in
inside a symbiote's own mindscape it
shouldn't be possible and yet here you
are because the normal function of
things is that the Symbiotes are
controlled by the host so the Symbiotes
exist in the host mindscape not the
other way around only one other
character was able to do this right
enter into the mindscape of a symbiote
and then effectively dominated and
control it from the inside out that
person of course being null the Symbiote
God and so Eddie tells him you manifest
weapons from your limbs here you fight
off Venom's figments haven't you ever
wondered why and when Dylan asks why are
you asking me this the response of Eddie
is I am the keeper Dylan Brock from the
beginning I have stood guard in front of
this cage and kept the monster contained
within but I am also the keeper of Eddie
Brock's Secrets meaning I am a memory of
what Eddie Brock was right I represent
one of his memories and that Eddie is
gone and I am tired and I have been
waiting for the day that I can tell you
the truth about what you are and so he
literally tells him before I do any of
that you're going to have to fight me
but you're going to have to demonstrate
your ability to face off against your
own father and to come out on top now of
course Dylan does right and in fact he
does it quite readily initially the only
reason why the fight lasts as long as it
does is because Dylan is hesitant to
fight he has more questions than
anything else but he's also exceedingly
uncertain of himself he's very confused
about himself and he really doesn't
believe in himself that much but once
that belief starts to come to the
surface and once he actually starts to
consider this possibility that he's a
lot more powerful than he initially
thinks he is then he in turn overcomes
Eddie and seemingly the blink of an eye
right literally like slashes at his
stomach and overcomes him now the reason
why this this memory of Eddie backs off
is because in any kind of real tangible
fight between the two of them Dylan
would have won he would have been game
over but such as it is they're in a
mindscape they don't have a physical
form so they'll always end up coming
back right they'll effectively be able
to fight forever and so where Dylan kind
of lashes out and asks like why are you
making me do this Eddie's memory
actually asks him that's not really the
question that you want to ask and that's
when we get this really really amazing
moment Dylan because he asked why did
you leave before all of this when you
got your powers you knew what you were
becoming why didn't you stay wasn't I
important enough now this is kind of
what Al Ewing was building on when it
came to Dylan and Eddie and so on and so
forth because for years and years and
years in Marvel Comics Eddie was just
the guy who used the Venom Symbian and
that was it right he was a disgrace
reporter with a grudge against Peter
Parker he was in the right place at the
right time the Symbiote bought it to him
the Symbiote was cast off by Peter so
through that shared hatred they became
Venom as we know him which is the guy
that hates Spider-Man now he's changed
in the Venom symbiote itself has
actually grown it's sort of adopted the
different personality aspects of its
different house and effectively
transformed into a good guy Eddie Brock
himself has had this massive character
Arc that's been going on for 30 years
and has been amazing to see basically
the Venom symbiote itself and Eddie
effectively becoming good guys all this
basically spearheaded and came into
Donnie Kate's Venom run when we got Noel
the Symbiote God and Noah was the guy
who controlled every symbiote everywhere
because he was the one that originally
made them where Eddie Brock was able to
finally defeat Knoll someone had to keep
the Symbiotes under control lest they
start bonding to hosts indiscriminately
and running amok Across the Universe and
so when Eddie did that he became quote
unquote the new King in black or the new
null or whatever you want to call him
but the guy that controls all symbiotes
Across the Universe the reality here is
that Eddie put himself in a situation
where he was basically the controller of
these symbiotes meaning he couldn't
necessarily be there for his son by all
standards of measurement he abandoned
Dylan albeit for a greater cause but
abandoned him nonetheless and that's why
Dylan Harbors so much sadness and so
much anger because he felt he felt
abandoned by his father even though he
understood why Eddie was doing at the
end of the day a son needs their father
and so the result of this is that as
Eddie has this conversation or really
the Eddie memory has this conversation
with Dylan what he says is I don't have
your answers after all I'm only the
memory of your father but I can tell you
this sometimes the only answers you get
are the ones you figure out for yourself
but that path began begins with stepping
out of the Shadows that fall so dark
upon you we must all overcome our
fathers one way or another maybe Eddie
Rock leaving had nothing to do with you
maybe Eddie's the fool who needs saving
son and so what happens is Eddie's
memory right this uh kind of symbiote
figment basically bonds itself to Dylan
and when that happens Dylan takes on a
new form where he's basically the Venom
symbiote but it's red instead of white
and I gotta be honest with you guys it's
only a small change but it looks amazing
like I love the idea of the Venom
symbiote which is like red and black
instead of white and black it just looks
dope man like it's just one change looks
amazing it just looks awesome and so
with this symbiote Dylan Brock basically
enters into the geode kind of into the
main Venom symbiote itself and then we
switch back over back over to sleeper
now here's a cool thing about this right
because Hank Hensley is a former spec
ops guy right Black Ops wet work high
high levels of military training being
bonded with a sleeper agent is just like
basically a super soldier right what
would habit of Captain America bonded to
a symbiote and then went on some
undercover mission to free someone from
one eye impregnable A Soldier of Fortune
write mercenary guarded base this is
basically it man like sleeper goes in
there and it's just like bam right like
throws down literally just these gas
bombs these guys start blasting it with
flamethrowers and so he's just like
rapid hardening fire resistant
polyurethane flamethrowers after all
this time really
please right and just like overcomes
these guys with a quickness right takes
them out super fast now at that point
that sees the entrance of Carson and
remember Carson is basically the the
main weapon that the life Foundation
uses right the Symbiote killer is what
they build after all their understanding
of Symbiotes and everything they know
and everything that they've they've
grasped about it they're like this guy
has all the arms and Armament we need to
defeat a symbiote no one can stand
against this guy wrong wrong
it's though it's the most amazing thing
ever right so like sleeper takes that
like this guy goes goes for like the
jugular right with with Carson and he's
like come on I laugh off your
flamethrowers and you bring a spear you
really don't get it do you right like
your resonant Nano material Spirit tip
it's cute it's adorable you know I I
love these little toys that you've that
you've brought to this conflict Carson
it's adorable to see a truck it's like
watching a baby walk for the first time
right you know you want to get it on
video so you can keep it for posterity's
sake because I am the most capable
symbiote that you're ever ever going to
face off against you think because you
caught me once that you know how
everything works let me give you insight
into symbiote's Carson we're infinitely
stronger with a host than without one
and even among them right now I am the
most powerful symbiote you've ever met
you come for that boy again and I will
tear you apart one molecule at a time
and the other thing about this is this
is the real kicker about this right the
life Foundation thought they had
symbiotes on lockdown we studied Venom
so we know what's going on with Venom
sleepers on a whole different level guys
it's why you don't see him very often
this entire story it could have all been
wrapped up like that if like the sleeper
just stepped in and just taking this guy
out this dude's a beast like I dude I
love Simba like I love sleeper so much
this guy's phenomenal but the other
thing that he reveals is he's like well
all this is going on you failed to
notice the most obvious thing Carson
self-replicating remote resident
ectoplasm I can copy myself and so what
literally happened is he duplicated
himself the duplicate grabbed Dylan and
then got him to safety while the other
version and faced off against Carson
Carson had no idea he had no clue what
was happening and so literally they end
up grabbing Dylan Brock with the help of
Archer and they take off and Dylan Brock
is officially safe and so what happens
here is we jump back to Dylan it really
Dylan's mind as he's in the mindscape of
the Symbiote and as he makes his way
through there's this kind of disembodied
voice that almost taunts him to a degree
right it says Dylan Brock The Keeper at
the gates having murdered my past now
you walk into my cage clintard what lies
at its heart do you know and of course
Dylan responds to the truth he said I
would find the truth here and Venom
response did he now perhaps in a way he
was right the truth is a mirror after
all so tell me Dylan who are you and
that's the amazing thing here is because
even Dylan doesn't know like it's
literally the Symbiote asking Dylan
questions that he can't possibly
comprehend now he doesn't really
understand any of this stuff and so when
he responds and says I am Venom and even
even just kind of really more of a
question than a statement the response
to the Symbiote is no not just yet you
can sense it can't you the meaning
coursing through the block I am Venom
who are you he says I am Venom who are
you and when he responds and says I am
Dylan Brock the response of Venom is son
of Eddie Brock but you have known deep
within yourself that you are more you
are my son as much as you are his who
are you and that's where Dylan just kind
of starts to flee and it's like no do
not run from who you are Dylan do not
run from what you're capable of do not
run from what you will become with every
cell dividing into another in Anne
weighing's womb you have known this
truth many times over yes you have known
this from the very beginning he taught
you to run from it all of your life
because he loved you but turning away
from a mirror does not let you run from
yourself each time you bond with a
klintar you rip them from The Hive you
can change your symbiote not by thought
but by Instinct I named you long ago
when you were born and I thought you
were the most beautiful thing then my
son I once told Eddie Brock the meaning
of your name and he thought it beautiful
too but he feared what it would mean for
you so he bound it to a terrible power
and hid it deep within my body reach
within me find it do you understand the
meaning of your name and so this is a
really really amazing moment because
what happens here is that while this
encounter is taking place right while
Dylan Brock is literally reaching inside
of the Symbiote and coming into his own
truly adopting what his power is because
this is just kind of like what you're
seeing here is really more of a physical
manifestation of the experience the
Dylan is having right it's like if you
could physically live the idea of you
understanding what you wanted to do for
a living right I want to be a doctor if
you could physically manifest that sort
of light bulb moment then that's what
this would be that's literally what's
happening here and so in the real world
sleeper and Archer grab the body of
Dylan and they take it to the Venom
symbiote and Dylan merges with a Venom
symbiote while that happens Dylan
himself in the mindscape is reaching
into the the Clint hark to see what he's
actually becoming and what ends up
taking place is that once he re-merges
with the Symbiote and he steps back out
again right he basically takes on his
physical form this is when Dylan becomes
the person he was always going to be he
becomes codex and so this is cool
because this is you know Al Ewing told
us this is what's going to happen and
really even Donnie Cates told us that
right this is what's going to happen
with Dylan now for those of you guys who
don't understand the significance of
this we've seen what happens when Dylan
becomes codex we saw it in an alternate
reality and again the link for that
video is down in the playlist so you'll
be able to see that as you're going
through the Venom stories that we've
covered so far but the long and short of
it is this guy becomes a symbiote god
that's literally what it is instead of
Eddie Brock having to kind of
consciously control the Symbiotes by
using his mind and kind of tapping into
their hive mind Dylan can control them
at will he can make them do whatever
they want to do that was the value of
the statement that was being made when
you bond with a symbiote you tear it
away from the hive mind that's literally
what takes place that when Dylan bonds
to a symbiote that symbiote is pulled
away from the hive mind that same it
could in turn pull others away from the
hive mind and so quite literally he can
expand the ranks of the of his symbiote
Hive exponentially right it just grows
at a geometric rate and that's literally
what happened when we saw the alternate
reality where where Dylan became codex I
won't go into the details I'll let you
guys watch the video to get caught up
and find out but it's amazing because I
will basically say that what happened is
Dylan essentially killed the Marvel
Universe but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later peace